gang before we hit the fun button in the
episode let's talk about the good old
middle class famous tour talking
stand-up show play a little ayg with the
crowd it's a good time grab the homies
grab the bozos grab your gal grab your
guy come out and see us we're coming
everywhere yeah guys we're going to be
in denver phoenix salt lake city chicago
chicago late show at it first so sold
out then we're going to be in rosemont
oh baby
then we're going to pittsburgh buffalo
and detroit and june get those tickets
we'll see you there
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is ru garbage sure is it's a little show
we sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find that if they're girl to be
classy yeah or if they're just a big old
piece of trash i'm your host dad trolley
coming at you on a beautiful day down
here at antoni's basement she's upstairs
selling girl scout cookies okay said she
caught a troop slipping all right so
they're second hand real cheap good
deals get them while they're in stock
gang my co-host is coming at you from
right next to me unamused this week at
my aunt toddy bit
he is the ceo of ru garbage he's
international businessman he's my
[ __ ] boss so do me a favor leave me a
nice yelp review talk me up a little bit
give it up for kj kevin james ryan hey
gang thanks for tuning in as always
please make sure you review subscribe on
itunes full video available on youtube
and as you know those numbers are true
and then um god damn it do you have your
notes in patreon.com backslash are you
garbage this is the greatest [ __ ]
website ever invented shout out to
samuel jack conte we love you guys sign
up uh you get bonus episodes at ayg
episodes of hard feelings this is a
completely different podcast live
streams there's a whole bunch of bonus
videos on there we did the cribs at each
one of our parents houses the whole
[ __ ] nine yards check it out plus a
lot of drama on that hard feelings you
gotta check it out they're nail biters
also
fat court season two is upon us yes it
is yes it is and i will not fail this
there's a lot of money on the line about
five g odds and i ain't got it speaking
of not having it how about a nice quick
shout out to our producer extraordinaire
the magic man one of my best pals he's
my driving in buddy we drive to work
together and you were late today
that's because we were smooching in
traffic give it up for t-bone mcstuffins
toby mcmullen everybody what's up dudes
what up t-bone we were late i got a ride
with the boss and i still felt like i
was in trouble yeah well you didn't ride
a room with me so you were in trouble we
were in my mom's car
proper in my mom's car i got the
explorer up here while the latitude's
getting worked on but that's either here
exploring how to be a loser
gang we could not be more excited and
i'm
couldn't be more serious we could not be
more excited to have our very special
guests here with us
she is a very funny stand-up comedian
podcaster she's a worker she performs
all over the country you've seen her on
a late show with stephen colbert and she
has her own amazing podcast called good
time gal she's literally
everybody's favorite comic everybody
talks about it everybody [ __ ] her
she's a great hang we started out in the
village together we climbed out of that
dump together doing open mics down there
but the big question about his mind
today is she garbage i gotta say about
two or three months ago i saw her take
down an order of wings like a chupacabra
well we're going to go through the
motions and check it out bones and hold
up for the one the only caitlyn palufo
everybody
i'm feeling good this is good this is a
hot one you guys are
great to see you
back and forth i might actually listen
to this
i might check these losers out yeah
[ __ ] on the intro
[Laughter]
well we'll put that in a post polo she
loves wings and she's a hot [ __ ]
that's my kind of girl
who doesn't want that
buddy thank you so much for coming in
thanks for having me this is thrilling
great i remember the land we met at the
village lantern we were you you would
just start a comedy right yeah i was a
baby bird [ __ ] took off like a rocket
man everybody loves you you're
absolutely fantastic everybody loves you
guys
sweet boys
that don't know me yeah it's very funny
everybody loves us but the three of us
hate each other so it's a great dynamic
rightly so
give us the backstory we'll fill us in
okay from your cali girl i'm a cali girl
i am i'm from san francisco
really yes i thought you were from
queens
i know i got a very uh i got a very i've
been here for 13 years okay really yeah
i've been here for a long time love it
really before you did comedy before i
did comedy yeah this is going to be a
juicy one oh a juice baby the amount of
times i've blacked out in this city is
overwhelming it's a lot it's a problem
yeah yeah yeah so hit us you go up
proper san francisco in the city oh
suburbs san bruno california yeah we you
know we have we have the airport okay
that's where we flew into san bruno
probably yeah you flew if you flew into
sfo you were in my backyard baby you
lived by the airport huh
yeah by the airport ain't great no no no
no we got an artichoke joe's which isn't
what the [ __ ] is that it's a casino
sounds like a pizza place nope not at
all that's the name of the casino
artichoke jokes yeah yeah yeah we have
like a whale we don't rip you off
no they'll get you
how to choke joe's we're gonna rob you
and you know it
yeah during covet they even had like the
plexiglass and they did a tent outside
so people could still come and gamble
you guys ever go to eat there as a
family no no no no um my mom wouldn't
allow it you know my dad my dad
he doesn't care he's just because he's
alone dad stop caring at a certain time
they're like i'll eat out of the trash
just like genuinely stop giving up yeah
that's gary right yeah
are you gary he could be the first
contestant we want to do if we want to
do a spin-off show instead of are you
garbage is called are you gary we bring
three guys in
and they've gotta figure out which one's
name's gary by a bunch of questions yeah
i think that's gary's are very specific
mm-hmm as you would know yeah very
specific they have a dog training camp
in their backyard well your dad's a dog
trainer no but he wants to be oh man he
really likes his dogs and so he built a
training ground yeah i'm opening up my
own hospital really he's got like the up
and down ramps is he real yeah he's got
the tube and then his dog died and so he
replaced it with a putting green so much
did he die on the course no no that's a
write-off yeah
he died under the porch
oh man dignity did he use the ramps and
stuff to make a mini golf course because
that's a good time no i think he he put
um a uh wishing well on top of one of
the ramps
but then there's a putting green back
this up
this guy spends a lot of time at home
depot
you're in the suburbs in san francisco
uh-huh single-family home sounds like
you live in a fun house
i'm guessing it sounds like circus folk
to me oh yeah we're very close uh but
yes single family home uh how many
brothers and sisters you have two
sisters older one younger oh you're the
middle child little baby how what's it
what's the separation there older sister
is five years older younger sister is
eight years younger
oh baby someone was a mistake i'm not
saying which one accident
a little too much fun out there at the
dog track whatever you got going on in
that backyard yeah that's crazy
and what does your mom and dad do
professionally professionally speaking
um my dad is a uh cabinet refinisher
okay and my mom was a handyman he's a
handler very handy yes and he's been
doing that since he was 18. he's got
very bad knees
yeah couple of uncles high-end stuff
we're talking thank you high-end very
high-end okay okay yeah yeah he's a
craftsman he's an artist i would say so
yeah and he's the lead finisher so i
used to have to work at his cabinet
okay she's a [ __ ]
toby you might have to cut that that
says something about you
yeah someone's good at uh the old
smoochy smoochy downtown
i don't know about that
i think you got it in them you seem like
an eater yeah
sushi sushi downtown that's why
artichoke joe's right yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah they sound like she's smooching
down there it's the side
all right here we go digging for oil
fatty huh you get in there
um
what'd your mom do my mom was a teacher
second grade teacher nice she's just
retired though she's all free very nice
yeah yeah packing it in relaxing what do
your two sisters do
older sister is a school nurse okay yes
and uh and married rich so great job
love that yeah really tech money no no
no uh country money like uh he's like uh
a driller
like a an oil drip not an oil driller
but he like drills for echo i don't if
you you couldn't pay me right now figure
out what he does but i know he has rigs
and he drills so he's hillbilly rich yes
hillbilly rich there we go do they live
out in san fran they live in sacramento
the suburbs of sacramento on like a farm
okay yes
yeah they have a pool house whoa
yeah that's that's country money that's
country not billiards like an actual
like swimming pool no they have a
billiards and they have a swimming pool
and a tennis court whoa i know i know i
know yikes but they but he also like
fishes and wears a lot of camo so let's
not get crazy
no teeth
[Laughter]
all right and get to the
younger sister no i was going to ask you
how does your dad start doing dog dog
training well he um what kind of dog was
it it was a uh oh my god he was a
schnauzer he was only training his dog
only training his dog for what like mma
what was he trying
i think he just like really got into it
depression's a hell of a thing okay
listen i'm big on you gotta fill the
time somehow there's a lot of stacks
when did he start doing this
uh he started doing it maybe like six
seven years ago okay and he took a class
and he really got into it he loved it
big fan of the class and so he was
training his dog ryder sweet boy had he
already had the dog he had already had
the dog so he wasn't trained in other
people's dogs
okay just his one dog just wanted his
dog to be the best dog yeah that
possibly could but my dad is like a
recluse he does not like being around
people and so he just basically built
that track in his backyard so that he
wouldn't have to go to the track and
deal with people wow yeah your mom and
dad still together yes okay yeah still
in love okay ish i think yeah still
going to smooch your smoothie
oh yeah that's the one thing that never
stopped they do the smoothie smoothie
downtown i don't know if you spend a lot
of time in the backyard building
racetracks
sounds like a loveless man you don't
want to be in the house i'm surprised
they're together
i was trying to be polite everybody's
got their hobbies i just bought pigeons
keep me in the backyard for a couple of
that's wonky that's a first that's an
ayg first oh really
i mean did you know anybody else with
that growing up uh no yeah no uh that's
making an american gladiator
[ __ ] for your miniature schnauzer
yeah i thought you would just say like
golden retriever
you're dead shooting it with tennis
balls
let's go iceman
and just to be clear it's not a big
backyard
give me like a ball i mean maybe the
size of this room what are you kidding
me yeah this is the size of our backyard
and there is a deck and then down like a
wow rolling ground oh no yeah how big is
that that's what the neighborhood's like
yeah it's it's super close together is
it grass or concrete uh well it's
uh original dirt and oh no grass okay
and then um and then he put
turf on top of the stuff
you're so you currently have astroturf
in your backyard yes currently what's
the front yard the front yard is marbles
gravel what are we doing
we have a very nice lawn we have a very
nice lawn we have and then my dad
collects a lot of figurines
like action figures and are you gary
this is
this is really shaping up shout out to
the big guy he's got to be he's got to
be on our life
we'll fly him out he's got to be on are
you gary he's a figurine
this is crazy
like uh you know like gnomes and stuff
but they make a whole bunch of stuff
it's
so he's a wizard
like that but it's like he does um like
disney figurines like mickey minnie and
uh how many give me a number a ballpark
well okay um uh we do have two homes i
will say that you do one's only for
gnomes
it's underground girl i mean that one of
them has like 30 gnomes the other one
has like 10. wait why do you have two
homes well my dad says marriage is great
well um my my nano r.i.p passed away
okay he was uh he did well and so he
left us some money and so my parents
were able to buy a little country home
okay um yeah it's very nice it's a tiny
little two bedrooms or three bedroom
situation nice where do you do something
like that out there uh up there we live
right near a lake so
my my rich because my rich
brother-in-law has a boat so we go on
there yeah up there and wow that's
pretty that's pretty good money when you
have a boat at someone else does he keep
it up there or he brings it he has i
think uh no he brings it okay i don't
know i don't have a trailer they have
two boats
i know i know whenever i go home i just
compare myself and it's really upsetting
yeah it's tough hold on though but they
work very hard sure but he he doesn't
drive the boat into the lake the boat
comes on a trailer uh they have two
boats they have one for like water
skiing okay and then they have another
boat for his fishing and he like does
[ __ ] on this on this hobbies yes so
they that's where they vacation or they
go out there yeah they go out there they
have a nice time but the boats live out
there
yeah and then if the one boat lives out
there the other boat he takes with him
so when he does competitive fishing he
takes it with them oh i know it's a
whole situation yeah i thank god that
they don't listen to podcasts because
i'm really airing that guy's definitely
not listening to are you garbage no i
can guarantee you that although he is a
little bit garbage yeah huh but in a
very nice way so two homes
yeah he's a nice course of course i
gotta make sure that's clear yes of
course that's that's understood are they
indoor gnomes or ones out like they're
grass so that's what he collects yes he
collects those i ran over one once and
he got he tried not to be mad but he was
like heartbroken i need to buy another
one so he doesn't have in the
house no my mom does the tchotchkes in
the house there's a lot of tchotchkes in
the house and then
giving an exhausting in this place must
be a mess
must be upside down
i mean i know what it is but what are
you the what are her cha cha well it
depends on the season okay there is
winter keys there is easter cha-cha keys
there are summer chachis there's
thanksgiving trotsky's it's she
decorates porcelain turkeys and things
like that and then also the figurines
that are like oh
three bears for her three daughters you
know it's like cherish teddies you know
what i mean and that's not lingerie
people
what's a cherished teddy oh well oh
they're there my mom loves bears you
said that like we come from tchotchke
people
i'm looking
[Laughter]
you're correct they are tchotchke-ish my
mom my mom collects i'm going to butcher
this they're called breyer's
carolers
ice cream she likes ice cream i collect
ice cream
no they're they're not porcelain they're
like
they're like muppets
or
i don't like dolls and they're they're
going like that they're singing
christmas songs yeah she has those yeah
but that's a christmas decoration yes
these are around all the time uh the
cherished teddies are around all the
time yes and then my sister has like
wooden ones that are like it's just
well not the cherished teddies but she
collects like these wooden angels
so they're like very i don't know we got
a live one i mean it's a lot it's okay
it honestly makes christmas buying very
easy because you just get the latest
teddy or whatever that angel thing is
and she's like oh and then my sister
also loves snowmen so you can just buy
her snowmen anything and she's happy
were you a beanie baby person girl yes i
was absolutely thank you so much i bet
your mom's stiller
wow waiting for that ship to come in
yeah yeah yeah
they're still in a tub in the in the um
attic and then my mom went through them
to see if they were worth any money and
they're not yeah so they are not should
have stuck with the baseball cards gary
he had him he had him
gary are you gary
so they still live in the same house
you grew up in i grew up in yeah so we
won't ask you the exact name of the the
residents but it's a big thing did you
grow up on a street an avenue a
boulevard a circle avenue it was a 7th
avenue yeah huh but it was it is there a
number in front of that or a name
a name okay i'll say it it's holly
avenue
[Music]
and because every year for christmas we
light up
um i've talked about it on other people
okay so i won't give you the number but
um
three that's three just look for the
gnomes
honestly the battalion of gnomes in the
front yard we might have to bleep it
yikes but every year we do christmas
decorations because it is uh christmas
street yes oh really wall street does
christmas decorations wow you guys all
get together now let me ask you do
people come and tour it
yes people drive slow on our street
really you're one of those streets one
of those streets you have somebody out
there
collecting a little money for the effort
no okay not even they do that walking
around they do that in brooklyn they
also do that in another neighborhood in
uh where i'm from
we're not those people nobody's
collecting no one's collecting it's free
take a look take a look we're doing this
for the leather game gary's up in the
window out of the shower
has a peek yeah yeah he does it my mom
loves it he puts it on a timer it's a
whole thing it's pretty good we leave it
up for a while too well i once a while
uh february march march
i'm sorry i think the headphones are
broken sound like you said february
march well my mom likes them she likes
the icicles so she likes to drive down
the street and see them it makes her
wait does he have icicle lights on your
house in the march
sometimes
growing up we would have them for a long
time because we were very busy colored
lights uh
well yes they used to be colored lights
and now they're led blue lights
from costco thank you
shout out to signature kirkland
very good stuff
fake christmas tree real christmas tree
uh
fake fake now you used to be real
growing up was real somebody allergic no
no no older it's tougher yeah but i
don't know it's got a deal at costco
oh no kmart sorry oh man yeah
people yikes
go to target like a respectable person
absolutely not huh did you go to a
public high school private school public
did you go to college i did twice
[Laughter]
i'm a doctor um that you would think for
how much i paid but nope where'd you go
i went to uc san diego or undergrad and
then i went to pratt institute for
graduate school here in brooklyn uh-huh
so now that leads us how you got out
here what'd you major in uh art i
majored in media studies in undergrad
and art history okay and then out here i
did um
it's called new forms
it's uh
it's uh
[Laughter]
i studied gnome history yeah
wait till you hear what i did um there
is not a better scam on earth than art
school i got to say 100
i couldn't agree with you that's a good
school though it is it is a very good
school you want to be a barista yeah
[Laughter]
and oh buddy i was
were you oh my god
let's talk about athletic greens aj one
ag one it's just called on the streets i
ain't talking ag3 i ain't talking ag2
i'm talking ag-1 first place of course
number one numero uno the gold star
the best let me tell you something about
athletic greens tell me tell you why i
started taking it why is that i started
taking it because and when i was in the
gym
well i started taking because they sent
me a free batch sure but then i re-upped
because i liked it so much yeah it
tastes great powers you through my
workouts all right it's absolutely
fantastic put a little on top of your
donuts it's a one-stop shop i'm telling
you right now immunity gut health the
whole nine yards it's like a super duper
duper duper duper multivitamin yeah it's
got 75 high quality vitamins minerals
whole food source superfoods probiotics
and adaptogens and at this point i know
what those are nice ah not really uh
it's lifestyle friendly whether you eat
paleo uh keto vegan dairy free gluten
free contains less than one gram of
sugars there you go no gmos no nasty
chemis artificial anything and it still
tastes great tastes great really does uh
tons of people are taking some kind of
multivitamin it's important to choose
one with high quality ingredients that
your body will actually absorb anybody
can just take them yeah you gotta absorb
them plus you get the cool shaker with
it you look cool it's green when you
drink it so it looks like i feel like
tony stark and iron man because he
always drinks sure like cool things yeah
so right now it's time to reclaim your
health and arm your immune system with
convenient daily nutrition one scoop one
scoop and a cup of water every day
that's it no need for a million
different pills supplements i take it
that i'm not taking you drink your ag
one you go you go to bed that's what it
is one scoop i've been doing four
okay
dude uh to make it easy athletic greens
is going to give you a free one year
supply of immune supporting vitamins
look at that five free travel packs with
your food purchase all you have to do is
visit atletico.com garbage again that's
athletic greens.com garbage take
ownership over your health pick up the
ultimate daily nutritional and shards
back to the show let's go back to the
show
i was a barista i was a brunch bartender
oh god
could only make bellinis and mimosas
that's it pretty much
oh but i could make them fast
you should have seen me
almost as fast as the little schnauzer
finished the course
i cranked out a bloody mary he never did
well
that's awesome i didn't think he was a
pro i mean
your dad thought he was grooming a
champion
oh my dad has the biggest heart of
anyone in the world he believed in that
little guy and that little guy was not
having it what uh what was the high
school mascot mustangs oh
american
the name of my high school yes
cappuccino
i'm sorry
you are a barista cappuccino high school
cappuccino high school that's no it's
not yes it is apparently back in the day
i went to london fog elementary school
so it all worked out
london's fun it's a deep cut yeah no but
i get it it's a steam tea i used to i
used to be a barista i thought it was
the raincoat you were talking about
it is as well it is
only universal
cappuccino high school yes you know
that's what we would say home of the
steamers
no nothing all
all right i laughed i was actively
laughing toby doesn't laugh it doesn't
count oh all right well he's looking at
him cappuccino hot that sounds like
something from like
a bad tv show yeah well the thing is
it's spelt differently because it was
the name of a ranch
a mustang ranch uh that was there before
oh mustang that's making a little bit of
sense cappuccino ranch
c-a-p-u-c-h-i-n-o so only one p so it's
not the actual drink
literally the amount of times i've said
this outside of my mouth it's just
insane
okay yeah good school
fine
yeah it was it was fine it was like your
run-of-the-mill public school okay but
with like um i guess uh
more working-class kids okay yes so we
didn't have we had like one rich girl
and she was like queen bee wow but she
had a bmw whoa did you hate her
um she was nice to me but she was mean
to all my friends wow yeah did she date
the hot guy in school
i don't think so okay
i wonder what she's doing
what were the grades like i did okay i
um
i got an art school i got an art school
but i played soccer and uh okay so that
got me into college oh really basically
is that a division one school d2 nice
yes and uh i got the bare minimum to get
into the school okay but uh i had like a
three six three seven but that school is
like for brainy people so the average
was four one four two
but because i played soccer they were
like that's okay
what were the sat scores looking like
1200 whoa
is that good yeah it's not bad it's
better than me i'm no longer the
smartest guy in the room oh you better
suck it
i got an 870. you did what
was that those are gnome scores
that's a real
gary did gary go to college no no he
went straight to work for his father
okay artiste yeah it was a family
business oh so that's the and by the way
we skipped over this
you referred to your grandfather i
believe as nano
i don't know italian italian very
italian okay all right i'll give you
that is your mother italian as well no
big problem yikes
what's she
she's uh like a european mutt she was a
little bit everything okay yeah yeah
yeah yeah italian english scottish
situation who did the cooking at the
house dad gary gary
cooks with love that guy yeah
he's got big hearts big guys he's got a
big heart and a big wooden spoon let's
stir that gravy
you got a big fan club out here on the
east coast
what would gary cook garrett a lot of
italian food nice he makes really good
meatballs with mozzarella cheese in the
middle whoa oh he hand rolls him the
whole thing he makes really good pesto
pesto appreciate pesto as you get older
yeah big pesto guys yeah i had i had a
cousin come in from montana and he was
like why is my pasta green and we were
like just put it in your mouth it's very
good shout out to pesto oh yeah yeah i
just started eating pesto maybe a couple
of years ago oh that's great it's good
it's nice thanks for having me what was
the name of the grocery store that your
mom went to uh my mom would go to either
uh
lennardy's which is very italian
that was right up the street then we
also only sold spaghetti uh we had an
albertsons and a lucky's safe
classy classy never heard of lucky's
though it it became albert since okay
yeah and then there's albertans they
were in the 90s they bought up
everything yeah they were cooking and
then it we
had a i believe it was safeway but then
it got bought out by
uh molly stones and it's too uppity for
us now oh molly stones is fantastic
my little sister started working there
so then we started going because we
would get the discount
we did the same thing yeah it's just i
was working what was your first job
my first job i was 16 and i was working
at a fitness center like a curves okay
it was called fitness express okay yeah
yeah yeah yeah you do oh this is so
counter girl or so i was the recruiter
and but i had to go recruiters oh yeah
yeah i would recruit in people to join
or people to work there to work uh to
join so i would go to like parking lots
of of like uh places and i'd have to go
to women who are like 40 and overweight
and be like hi you want to join our gym
not that you need it but would you
hey fatty can i talk to you for a minute
literally that's what i look back at it
now and i was like if one of those
little [ __ ] came up to me i'd kick
him in the [ __ ] i just heard i'm sorry
you pull out you pull out a bag of
skittles you got a couple of minutes
yeah
yikes yeah yeah yeah
recruiting 16 and 17 yeah cause i was
very fit
i was like yolked i looked back at
pictures of myself i was like [ __ ]
yolked because i never heard a girl be
like yo i was [ __ ] young
but i was like thin but i was like i had
like abs and [ __ ] gotcha but not on
purpose yeah not on purpose it wasn't
like a active i probably didn't even
know i had abs
you know what i mean does gary work out
no no he tries he goes for a walk and
then sometimes he hit these
bands and oh this is another thing at
one point ryder the dog he went blind
and so he got a scooter and he would
take uh ryder on watch course numbers
went real down dude he's got a real
lemon here
i don't understand this and he put a
sign on the the scooter or the the buggy
and it said blind dog oh good gary blind
dog on board does gary have a mustache
he's got just like a goatee situation
and mostly it's in the neck i figured
yeah gary's the best gary's all right
gary sounds great yeah tell you are you
gary's got real potential
it really does
[Laughter]
nbc
okay let's do some more you garbage
questions okay
before before we still in the backstory
a little bit what was the family
vacation like growing up oh well we
would go my
grandparents they built their own cabin
in the woods in the same area that my
parents bought their cabin they built a
cabin it was like a a-frame
two-bedroom cabin we would all sleep on
the deck and then outside yeah we would
sleep outside and um
we went in january
but we would spend my mom as a teacher
and my grandparents are both teachers so
we spend all of our summers there oh
that's a lot of fun yeah yeah and then
all the cousins would too and then my
grandparents had a motor home so we
would travel around the u.s
um we'd go to koas and sleep in this we
called it the magic pumpkin koas
i'm sorry hang on
now these are your mom's parents we're
talking about these are my mom's parents
yeah
so i have this car sound like travelers
going from town to town ripping people
off so just so i have this understanding
sure gary's dad owned his own company
gary's dad owned his own company that
gary worked for for a few years and then
he branched out and did his own thing
yeah he needed health insurance so he
had to go and that grand and that
grandfather did very well yeah
grandfather did very well and did your
mom's grandparents do well they were
both teachers um and they did well you
know they had uh are they still with us
one grant my grandma is she's 96 whoa
does she live in the in the house by the
lake
she does yeah during covet she lived up
there because no one could touch it and
then you guys have the house by the lake
yeah now we have another house by the
lake okay
that's right now who at the rv
grandma your mom's my mom's grandma yeah
and you guys would go on family
vacations
in their rv with your grandparents yes
you your three sisters gary and your mom
yes and you would go to where koa's koas
we went to like wyoming during the
nineteen ninety-six elections
down there
of america yeah campgrounds of america
campgrounds of america
it's like
a one-stop shop you can just go and they
have everything set up you're not like
you know just driving into the woods did
you say you drove to the olympics yeah
we drove to the 1996 olympics in atlanta
in atlanta did you get tickets yeah yeah
we went to go see um the women's soccer
team okay oh that's fun because we went
my sister was on a soccer team and so
they like planned a trip so that the
team could go around and now where do
you park the car where do you park the
camper
you park it in a koa and then you take a
bus
you didn't pull the car behind you no
you took a bus i think so my i think
yeah we didn't have a car
what'd gary say about all this gary um
he conveniently had to work a lot yeah
yeah classic gary but that [ __ ] yeah
kidding me guys he's got meatballs to
make gnomes
what i got a whole plate of sauce here
what are you doing [ __ ] driving to
atlanta to watch a girls soccer team
cake rocks he was the coach
really gary was the coach yeah he was a
heart of gold this gary wow he was our
soccer coach and so he was right down to
meet us not at your high school he did
the jv team but not the varsity you're
telling me gary
was the junior varsity stand here and
tell me gary was the jv coach the head
coach cappuccino high cappuccino
mustangs yeah he also taught me how to
do hurdles he was the track coach
varsity track coach when does gary have
time to sleep yeah
and what's that meatball recipe gary
definitely doesn't have time to drive to
[ __ ] atlanta yeah
gary's got nine irons in the fire over
here
don't wonder where your cappuccino hides
higher take a break that's crazy yeah he
was the head track and field coach yeah
jesus christ poor man he loved it plus
he's trying to train the goddamn dog
he got the dog later that's okay we
didn't have a dog at that point working
on his own special olympian in the
backyard
i just pictured him out there with a
stopwatch like all right you're doing
pretty good rascal
it's over in the neighbor's yard yeah
he's running into the wall licking
himself something
no pets growing up we had two dogs and
two cats
um but they were like outdoor animals
whoa let's put a quick button in that
what do you mean outdoor animals like
the the cats we had a window open in our
garage and they would come in and out
and they would did you buy these cats no
no no
yeah they were someone else's cats
these are feral animals these were your
neighbors cats midnight was like
aspca and then she was pregnant and so
i actually saw them give birth that is
what a thing
gary probably delivered them
doctor doolittle over here care take a
break if you're
if you're out there this guy drives the
bus to school coaches the team probably
the principal is there anybody else in
his goddamn cappuccino town he's doing
everything gary's holding up the guy the
other dad something
i mean he's doing laura on top of being
a master craftsman we're gonna find out
that gary was a set of twins
it's like multiplicity
gary figured out a way to clone himself
in the early 70s
shout out to gary
all right so you bought the one cat or
you got it from the spca aspca and then
she was pregnant and so she had kittens
and then we kept one kitten okay and
they they would go outside inside we
would feed them in our garage and so we
had like a doggie door open sure so they
never came into the house yeah they came
into the house okay what'd you do with
the other kittens yeah the kittens we
gave them away okay uh my aunt has one
baby
the other one i don't know i think we
gave it to a friend what's this were the
dogs outside dogs they were outside dogs
what does that mean we had um it means
they weren't
okay
it's definitely different
i mean you're a 90s kid nobody had
outdoor dogs
unless you were a tracker or something
well we had um we had a a porch outside
like it was a patio so it was covered
still outside it still has it
goddamn it
and we had like a dog bed and a doggy
houses and stuff like that they come in
the house yeah every once in a while
yeah yeah yeah but mostly
cigarettes they were outside
when they ran out of cigars yeah
you guys are going to atlanta for the
week you don't say
when will that be
what's the combo to the safe again
did gary have a safe no did gary have
any nickel what are you a gun guy no no
no no no my my dad i think was in a
fight once in high school oh he's a very
who the hell would hurt probably beat
himself up
[Laughter]
i can't find one guy to kick my ass
and when you want something done right
you got to do it yourself
man any job worth doing is worth doing
right
all right this is who friends growing up
yeah i had friends no gary
do sleepovers and all that yeah
no he did not
no yeah we did we did sleepovers were
you a bad kid i was the bad kid i was
the horny kid the horny kid yeah the one
that would always talk about sex and
and had crushes on boys okay yeah yeah
yeah all right did you get any trouble
yeah oh yeah what did you do nothing bad
like i didn't do drugs or drink or
anything but no drinking no but i would
really sneak out of the house and like
go see boyfriends and
stuff i know doing things not until my
senior year okay i was a tease
yeah yeah yeah i can't be giving away
the goods
gotta keep the boys talking coming back
for more yeah but i already wouldn't
allow that
gary didn't raise a [ __ ] all right no
he did
[Laughter]
god damn it gary this guy does it all
you try your best with these kids you
can't yeah you know he's very proud
but he says he can only see me perform
once a year
oh yeah yeah he's [ __ ] busy what do
you mean
guys up to his eyeballs
jeez honestly not until this podcast did
i realize how much my parents were doing
yeah what the [ __ ]
are they retired now or anything my mom
is retired my dad has two years left
okay yeah yeah i mean two years
uh until he retires until he's 65. yeah
okay yeah he's gonna he's gonna get out
when he's 65. yeah he's done you do it
gary yeah yeah yeah yeah he's gonna go
up to the lake and just [ __ ] sit yeah
gary drink is he like a cocktail guy he
used to yeah but he is now no longer
quit drinking good drinking goodness
this guy i mean he wanted to say
he's lived he wanted to save his
marriage why drinking was getting an
issue
when is it not i mean
well i think he realized that the only
time that they really fought was when he
was drinking okay he was like it was
never anything bad what was his drink
beer really loved beer loved whiskey
yeah and so he gave it up i love you pal
gave it up gave it up for his for his
wife and his family yeah [ __ ] rock
solid this guy tell you right now
you on the other hand i know what a mess
of speaking out the kiss i know i did
garage you guys have a garage we had a
garage but it was filled with too much
[ __ ]
couldn't park a car no no car in there
was it a two-car garage or one car one
car garage okay do you have a
refrigerator in there no no garage
fridge huh no garage fries and imagine
gary had another freezer or fridge
somewhere in the house no we just had a
really really full fridge one fridge man
one fridge man huh yeah just when you're
thinking no guys yeah
it turns you upside down kind of car
does gary drive
i don't know why this is really becoming
back gary is he single by any chance
yeah
what'd your parents drive growing up uh
growing up when i was little we had a
brown arrow star
that's the worst color worst car ever
talk about a turd machine yeah
it was that thing's a log rolling down a
highway it wasn't fighting the boys off
with a stick huh did it smell like eggs
a lot of them smell a lot of those arrow
stars all smell like i mean rotten eggs
i'm sure eventually yeah the catalytic
converter i think is what it was we had
that and then we had a red suburban
that's nice yeah we had a very we called
it the suburbity bourbon
a 90s suburban the old school yes the
old school ones the boxy ones yeah yeah
they're great though
it was very it was fun because it had
like a tv in the console really yeah you
could put uh uh
tapes in you know vhs vhs so then when
we were driving [ __ ]
like in the front or in the back in the
back for the kids yeah yeah so we would
watch like disney movies i've never
heard of a v8
no they were big in the conversion vans
did you have to put the tv in there
we bought it that way you bought it that
way because a lot of those conversion
vans came with an empty spot that you
would just have to put like a nine inch
tv and with and you can pull one in with
the cassette player yeah huh yeah yeah
yeah we bought it used we i don't think
my parents have ever bought it my mom
just bought her first car really yeah
they actually they just did
not too long ago they bought two new
cars but my dad bought a bright blue
truck and my mom's color choices on
these people is fun it is like your
shirt like that's the color of the trunk
what kind of truck forge chevy what is
these ford they bought only by american
really
cause they're patriots gary's a [ __ ]
patriot
yeah my mother driving a comedy truck
yeah my mom is the one who was like
we're buying american and he's really
okay yeah where are these tchotchkes
being made oh who see
exactly what's the other way yeah no
louise but louise is uh you know she's
louise and gary i know in my head on the
side of the truck it's wrapped and it
just says gary inc we do it all
i'll find the time
i'll pencil you
[Laughter]
all right let's do it here all right
that's fine this is a wonky one wonky
yeah it's a good yeah it's a good thing
you're all over the place yeah i know
we're we're like um we're
like we're liberal trash i feel like
yeah okay yeah very open-minded but boy
not classy folk were you a picky eater
growing up no we we ate what was in
front of us and you better eat it really
yeah did you pack your lunch or buy your
lunch at uh cappuccino high uh when i
was in high school i would usually bring
my lunch but when i was
younger gary would pack her lunch and it
was like we'll see what happens really
oh yeah i remember one time we got a
tortilla with peanut butter in it just
rolled up i don't hate it i gotta be
honest with you i would crush one of
those right now
and then it would just be like a full
carrot yeah just like whatever you're
the only kid in third grade eating pesto
it was our our lunches were always just
like uh because they're because my dad
didn't always cook
my mom got too busy at work and so he
was she was like you're home at two
o'clock you get to take over sure dinner
time and so there was like a learning
curve where it was like a two-year
period where you were getting like
carrot casserole just whatever whatever
just mashed potatoes yeah exactly
the bob evans ones
oh those are all right did when you took
a lunch did you take brown bag or do you
have a brown bag yeah okay brown bag no
lunch box
uh i would lose it all the time but i
always wanted one and my mom would be
like [ __ ]
yeah
brown bag and keep it moving yeah keep
it moving do you eat your pizza crust
yes and i dip it in ranch
okay
i love it so much hidden valley though
yeah get away from them we're not crafts
get out of here um do you know how to
use chopsticks yes
but i grew up in the bay area uh true so
i know i know chinese food and i know
mexican food okay nice yes but does gary
like sushi no no he doesn't eat seafood
at all
wow no hates it wow he thinks it smells
okay we would have like an argument
our family reunion we would do a crab
chipino but our family was the only
family that didn't eat seafood so he
would cook ribs your whole family
doesn't eat seafood my mom does and then
the rest of us do not i do now i moved
to new york and then i tried seafood and
i was like this stuff is good but it's a
pizza fan i'm a big chip oh see i don't
like cooked seafood i don't like raw
seafood
like
sushi yeah i like sushi um
i like like a tartar stuff like that
from cocktail fancy yeah i'll do a i'll
do a shrimp cocktail but cooked shrimp
it's like rubber same with like trout
and
salmon trout
mountain folk
that's hillbilly [ __ ] right there foxy
you ever have perch
if i went to a restaurant they had
shroud on the menu okay
i was at a fancy joint
uh i don't care how nice the boat is
catfish is catfish yeah
trout i'll have the goldfish please
grilled any sunnies back there
and he's stunning
you brush your teeth in the shower
i used to yeah
i mean yeah why'd you stop um it depends
on if i'm in a hurry okay but i'll do it
so you don't leave the toothbrush in
there no it would be like uh that's
assuming i shower every day get out of
here do you not no this is the first
time i showered in three days that's how
much i love you guys
i appreciate that
three
three days yeah what did you do the last
three days well i we just got a kitten
right and um
and i had to do like a one-off art
handling job
and so it was a lot of travel a lot of
kitten and i usually my routine is i
work out and then i shower but i haven't
had time to work out so it didn't even
completely there's a wrench in the mix
yeah of course yeah that i had that i
hadn't showered but i do that all the
time where you kick it a little bit what
do you mean it smells yeah oh for sure
what's the art you said an art job art
handling yeah i install artworks like in
art museums and art galleries what yeah
that was that used to be my day job
mm-hmm like
would give me an exam like at the met
yeah yeah yeah like all this stuff on
the wall there's like
you mean the art
all that [ __ ] they got in here
we don't know what a museum is yeah have
you been
you know stuff on the wall but even like
the placards and stuff like i would be
in charge of like hanging those up and
then it's also storing the art and then
sometimes if you're doing a new
exhibition you have to build a wall so
it's like construction did you work for
a company that did this um i worked for
individual galleries and museums like
solo yourself
just you show up yeah
wow um it's pretty [ __ ] interesting
and then you have to be a part of
sometimes you're part of a team
sometimes there's depending on how
science how big the pieces are and then
we go to rich people's houses and
install their art that's always a kick
because you got to go into like the
service elevator sure you can't go in
with that how did you get in and start
doing that i went to art school and i
was handy because of my dad
so they would ask me to help them
install their work okay and then a guy
uh i went to art school with ended up
working at a gallery and they needed
people so he asked if i wanted to do it
wow and so it literally i've never
written a resume for it but i've worked
for like maybe 10 galleries in museums
pretty interesting that just really
pulled you out of the fire
of being garbage she's a female
construction worker
let's not get crazy
no i'm wearing dickies and paintings
yeah
is there any artists of notes whose work
you've hung i mean i've heard themselves
uh dr seuss
hey nerd alert
[Laughter]
you said that so seriously i loved it by
the way
i've hung on like a warhol before whoa
wow yeah yeah who's a nerd now [ __ ]
yeah dave warhol yeah
you know eddie warhol yeah yeah pleasure
to the cubs right
yeah sometimes i get like impressed and
so i'll like touch it just because i
can't you know i love that
touch of greatness yeah that's pretty
cool i touched
evan essence's grammy
whoa that is the
what a weird crashiest statement
that has ever been said
in this [ __ ] room i did i touched it
i thought it was a guy named as you were
saying i thought you almost said it was
a guy named evan essex wait are you
talking about wake me up inside yeah
yeah i can't wake up
i don't know what it is i can't wake up
just wake up
what how does how does that happen
i never she bragged
like you were talking about andy warhol
in one breath
you guys know p.o.d right
you know the guys from house of pain
[Applause]
well that happens because uh apparently
evanescence is very like christian
okay and uh um i was friends with this
girl who uh whose ex-husband was uh in a
christian
pianist christian band and that band was
house-sitting for evanescence in their
the whole band
they're a part of the city how big is
this house i mean hey i'm gonna need
everybody in a room the whole entire
time i'm gone okay hey you don't want
the keyboard player too do you yeah
bring them yeah and so we had like the
after party there and they showed us
around and there was a grammy and i was
like can i touch it and he was like i
wouldn't and i was like okay
i touched it anyway
um real rule breaker and then they
prayed before and it was just me and my
friend who were drinking so it was
really embarrassing but then they had to
like pray
because they were gonna listen to a song
and so that we all had to hold hands and
me and my friend were like what the [ __ ]
oh yeah yeah it's too much that's a lot
too much you saw that [ __ ] on the
airplane where they broke out into a
christian song no oh yeah just recently
i would have jumped out the [ __ ]
window jesus christ yikes oh babe i'd
take a baby over that give me a baby
yeah i don't mind a baby crying you got
the headphones unless it's like on your
lap you know yeah now listen you
mentioned the cat you got a new kitten i
got a new kitten however
i love all kitty cats doggies and
animals okay okay
tell kevin
what kind of cat you got um well we have
two okay we have a devin rex and then we
have a sphinx we just got a sphynx cat
that's the one that looks like ari
shafir
no no it's the one that has no hair
that is the one that looks like aries
your fear
he is so handsome he's my handsome
little guy he's so small he's so cute i
knew that was gonna skeevey out dude do
you wanna see a picture
come on i just wanna see a little
picture sure oh come on
live a little he's my little handsome
guy
look at his name is benny
so i show it to the camera yeah stop
beating that thing after midnight
yikes
he's a little baby they just took my
soul
he's got human eyes on him and he's made
of foreskin oh my goodness he's so easy
those are the cats that look like aries
he's adorable yes i knew that was gonna
ski
man
i'm allergic to cats that's the book of
eli
[Laughter]
no way i imagine he was probably a
couple of dollars
i spent more money on
cats in the past two years and i've
spent time because
your other cat's kind of a specialty cat
too yeah she's hypoallergenic so she has
curly hair she's the cat that has curly
hair yeah she's no beauty queen
she's got a look to her wait what's it
called a dex ryan a devon rex a devon
rex or rex ryan p-o-n-r-e-x
d-o-n d-e-v-o-n-r-e-x
devon rex sounds like a private eye
yeah i'm on the case don't you worry
yeah one more thing
sorry i couldn't help myself fairies
that cutie pie it's got put your keys
it's cute yeah that's a little baby that
looks like an old man
here go to pictures go to pictures what
why not a tabby a maine [ __ ]
it is a tabby but it's a um devon red
that thing steals gold
yeah i spent a lot of money yeah no that
there are you know that is cute they got
cute little ears can we get a number
what'd you drop
on each cat or together
let's say each cat each cat um
the devon rex was 1400. holy [ __ ] and
the sphinx was 2100
because it's also an elf swing so its
ears are weird but that was that's two
g's on a cat yeah yeah yeah get one in
the [ __ ] park yeah but it's gonna
make me sneeze and have my eyes water
and i've oh wait i think they're
adorable i've always wanted one and so
steve's reluctantly very cute let it
happen
where do you pick up a two thousand
dollar hairless cat you well hell
the fiery depths of hell
[Laughter]
uh a lot of research
a lot of like we found oh boy
sorry big man's going
oh
down
got a little extra huh
sauce
ah it's on my penis
oh god
uh we got it in uh new jersey but i did
a bunch of research because i didn't
want sometimes these breeders like
overbreed the moms and stuff so i made
sure it was like an ethical breeding
place that's why it was also more
expensive dropping two g's on a cat
that's pretty cool it's a lifelong dream
i've i've wanted one since i was like in
college
it's pretty close they're so cute i love
i follow a lot of them on instagram but
now i don't have to because i got my own
little guy are you gonna make an
instagram account for the cat we have
one for our other cat so we might just
tag it on and be like welcome benny
there you go
benny and bowie i like it thank you
names yeah great names bowie's for the
rockstar benny is for benny and the jets
very nice because we just want to go in
and be like benny
love it
big fan do you have a preference of wing
do you like the actual wing of the
drumstick oh i like the wing you're like
give me a flat flap
do you remove one of the bones when you
eat it uh yeah you got to get in between
like you take it off and snap it and
then
hachimachi my friend ethan sp taught me
how to eat wings okay he talked about
trash
he i ate my wings he saw that there was
still meat on the bones he finished my
wings
holy [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah i was so
impressed
but i do bring it up to everyone i've
ever met him
that's wild
yeah does gary wear an earring yes
really he does he does he's got an
earring oh yeah he had a hoop or a stud
it's a stud it's a it was a dolphin for
a while a dolphin a dolphin and then a
turtle and he pierced it because my
middle school
team or my sister's middle school team
went undefeated and said that you do
that then i'll pierce
the man of the guy when he got his
world's coolest dad plaque did you help
him hang it yeah
he wouldn't need help he just
he'd do it by himself
he'd find the time you travel a lot oh
yeah you move around a lot um do you
bring food on the airplane with you uh
no
i get so anxious on airplanes i uh i
literally i get in as late as possible
sit down and put in headphones i don't
even take snacks
tsa free check yes and clear whoa that's
how little i want to be in that airport
sure wow i just don't like to fly uh no
i don't mind flying but i just don't
like
um the process the process okay yeah
take your shoes off on the airplane
no no you got name brand luggage no i
got amazon basics yeah what's a credit
score like uh not great maybe six
something six ten six twenty low sixes
low six how do we get something is
always whenever you say it's something
it's the low end of that oh yeah yeah
cause you would have said it's high
sixes no no no it's i think actually now
i've moved it up to middle sixes mid six
mid six tough i'm high sixes right now
i'm 699. i was 745. that's great i don't
know what happened 403 huh
[Laughter]
i could get up to 6.99 if you'd like
okay is that a threat you're going to
get fatter
to drag you around the
country um no i had uh credit card debt
when i moved to new york okay i was not
smart with my credit cards and i maxed
out like four of them nice what kind of
cards are we talking what do you got
discover yeah that was the big one that
[ __ ] me up ew yeah discovered that i
had bank of america
chase and capital one
i know but now i got rid of all of them
um i took out a loan and then paid those
off and so i'm paying off the loan and
now i just have my amex that i use for
uh comedy stuff good for you yeah amex
so that's good yeah the delta amex
who'd you get the loan from my family oh
very nice in-house gotta love that nice
low interest rates
no interest rate yeah and actually i was
going to do it through a um a bank but i
was about to do it when covet hit and my
mom was like don't do that [ __ ] just
we're gonna pay this nice and then uh
and then you'll pay us back so i'm
paying them back currently charging you
a vague or no uh gary wanted to mom said
no really he's a businessman he's a
businessman today i don't care how big
that heart is cash talk right
not bad someone's gotta pay for the
putting green you know what i mean yeah
yeah
huh have you ever heard of oh sorry no
they just said do you miss any of those
payments
um
i probably have are they loose they're
pretty loose but uh i have pride about
it so they apparently feel terrible
i would have paid a couple and then just
kind of
i mean
no i
i try and get it
as soon as i get one big check it's all
going to louise and gary there you go
but we're also talking about like we're
not talking about like 20 grand we're
talking about like design
oh okay yeah yeah it's manageable nice
yeah hmm
have you ever had a voicemail where you
were like hello hey i can't hear you no
trick voicemail no no but i used to do
the music
i would play my favorite song
evanescence
call me back tonight do you think i
won't put that on now i'll be back
um wow when the pollutors go out to
dinner
do you guys ever order the same thing is
there a place that you went to where
like the lemon chicken was really good
and you all got the lemon chicken
well i don't know about that but we go
to the same pizza place and are the same
things since i was two years old what do
you think about that though you get the
extra large number two which is um
it's sausage salami and mushrooms with
garlic on top okay it's very good and uh
one time i remember in high school my
mom called and he was like hey
congratulations this is your 500th order
whoa
second grade oh my god no no i think it
was i was in high school oh i think you
said i was in second grade oh sorry
you've been going since second grade i
apologize so it was like 500 pizzas
yeah just want to let you know you've
spent a lot of your money here that's
awesome yeah but sometimes we get a
salad
any injuries as a child yeah i broke my
wrist okay um trying to roll her blade
backwards okay my mom didn't want to
take me to the hospital so she said i
had to wait three days
it was definitely broken and she goes it
better be broken yeah i don't think
parents do that why didn't you want to
take you to the hospital because it's
time
damn you're the same way i was like if
you couldn't make it through the night
yeah it was like here take advil see how
you feel if you don't make it through
the night or the morning then we'll
we'll reassess three days with a broken
wrist i think it was two or three yeah
the [ __ ] revenant jesus christ and
then i broke my finger too and my mom
just put my uh oh sister's old splint on
it i was like here you go splints back
in the day we were poor we were poor
teachers don't get paid anything sure
splints were all right yeah a little
tape
oops sorry oh my goodness blowing up
the boss
do you eat ice
do i eat ice yeah
uh sometimes yeah i'm not gonna do it
now because the sound but okay it
depends on how hot it is
uh have you ever used the chili cheese
machine at a 7-eleven
chili cheese i've used the cheese okay
but not the chili you have a go-to fast
food wendy's really love a wendy's
serious yes they have the best chicken
nuggets
and then their fries are pretty good and
then i get a frosty i love a frosty okay
i don't know if i agree with you on that
chicken nugget they're very what what
what's yours
mcdonald's get the the inventor of the
chicken it's slime it's not even crispy
on the outside
she's talking crazy
points thank you sorry
um hmm
grown ups you keep the batteries in the
fridge
no what does that do except for dirt
bags think it prolongs them no okay
no ever owned a beanbag chair
no but i did own a papasan what the hell
is that
like a papa john's what is it no it's a
papasan it's they're from like um pier
one imports it was that round chair with
a cushion
oh i know what you're talking are you
talking about yeah it's like wood you
say quicker it's like bamboo yes you sit
in it it's almost like a cocoony thing i
didn't know you were an african warlord
i am we actually just got one of those
really nice
yeah it's very comfortable it's not so
much
you don't like it and it's more like
a little bit yeah yeah yeah it's loungy
will you eat food on the subway
yes you will
give me an example
like ollie when i was working my day job
i wouldn't have time so i would get egg
white bites from starbucks i would sit
on the train and i would eat those those
are fantastic that's easy-peasy very
good yeah yes they're a whole little
omelette thing
good situation it's so quick and easy
barely any calories if you ever would
you ever buy food in the subway you ever
stop at the churros lady or anything
like that i've always wanted to but i've
never had the guts okay
churros are good the churros are good i
wouldn't do the fruit when they hand out
the mango the mango looks good though i
know but there's the hands that have
been on that it's very it's very
intimate to cut a mango okay churros
even if they're wearing gloves
are they
yeah well now they are
now that you gotta oh what's your tattoo
on your arm oh this is for my sisters
they're pine needles
um because the my grandparents cabin
where we grew up they had two big pine
trees out the front deck that we would
sleep under
and so there's my older sister me and my
younger sister oh that's very very sweet
very tight with your family yeah yeah
how often do you talk to gary gary texts
me all the time really of course he does
he has uh track my iphone and so i leave
it on for him and so whenever i'm on the
road he's like what are you doing in
des
moines mind melding over here look at
that that was incredible that was
something else gary no you i'll have
your children
[Laughter]
um
yeah man you're an open person i would
never want anybody to know where i am or
what i'm doing it makes sense feel good
like he gets he has anxiety
and so he uh he likes to know where his
kids are and so whenever he's feeling
like lonely or starting to spiral he'll
just like message his kids and be like
what's going on there you go and so
he'll check and uh i'll be either on the
road or whatever and be like what are
you doing
um i have a an
uh instagram message like of all the
times he's asked me like just being nosy
what you doing just being nosy just
checking in how you doing yeah that's a
good dab he's a good dad were you a
crystal light family growing up no but
my aunt was and so i've had it
yeah what was the beverage in the
refrigerator at the polufo's coca-cola
and milk coca-cola you have milk with
dinner milk with dinner nice see look at
that
strong bones baby coke also comes from
gnome people so you're not you're not
eating you're not even great [ __ ] no
iced tea or anything like that no
coke and milk that's american baby milk
always coke not pepsi no my mom would
change her order if someone said we have
pepsi products is that okay she'd be
like no wow i'll take water
with extra lemons yeah louise yeah
louise means it not screwing around
she was the tough one and my dad was a
softy
you ever walk up to a drive-through
uh
i tried to in college yeah but they
wouldn't serve us
i mean have you ever ridden a mechanical
bull yes
have you or any member of your family
claim to have seen
an unidentified flying object i'm
pretty sure my that's up my cousin
jimmy's big jim's alley
really jimmy's seen some [ __ ] jimmy's
seen some [ __ ] wow yeah yeah yeah you
know the story no
no but that just sounds about it that
sounds very big jim
if there was somebody it's big jim yeah
yeah yeah
i would honestly when you meet him he'd
be like yeah he's probably seen it and
been like not a big deal yeah yeah i've
seen that what's the sleeping situation
at the house now uh how many pillows do
you have on the bed right now i have oh
god seven seven how many to sleep with
two
both under your head
one under my head one holding nice okay
one is for the sham that looks good
gotcha and then one is a throw pillow is
there a fan on you
no
no
when you go to sleep no sometimes i do
the calm app okay all right yeah the
little sleep stories sure those are nice
okay and now our cat's our little benny
sleeps with us he comes under the covers
and youth cuddles snuggles jesus hey
he's freezing he's got no hands yeah
he's got to do something
um
is there anyone in your family you call
by not their name
like
auntie or like a
aunt jojo
uncle uncle more
gold marbles
um well maybe big jim
but what's his name
[Laughter]
no i would say we're all very much okay
i can't think of no wonky nicknames no
wonky nicknames
have you ever uh ever had your hair
braided on a tropical vacation i had my
hair braided at camp
yeah never go on a cruise
yes a disney cruise as a family as a
family i was 27 it was very sad whoa
holy [ __ ] yeah for the grandkids or for
the grandkids i'll give you that yeah we
went to alaska
that's fun they go to alaska yeah yeah i
saw a glacier [ __ ]
all right
uh belly button ring no i always wanted
one i always wanted a belly button ring
and a nose ring but my mom wouldn't let
me get anything pierced until i
graduated from college
so i had 10 holes in my ears because
that's the only thing she would let me
do so i had 10 piercings in my ears and
then i grew out of it thank god
it's such a strange thing not till you
graduate college yeah toe ring
yes
on you now no no no no but i used to any
anklets i used to yeah but then i would
have to take them off for a call for
soccer okay same with the toe rings once
oh that was a cut not good do you ever
wear any pins did i what pins were any
pins gary's into pins gary gary and
louise are into pins how about that yeah
they go to disneyland and they collect
them
and they go along their lanyards do they
go alone they go alone yes
[Laughter]
we got disney adults gang
red alert call the cops
my whole perspective of gary has changed
no getting it he likes a good time a guy
of course he does he's got him listen
gary you're a hard working guy he
deserves it all right
dude take as many disneyland trips as
you [ __ ] need pal i'll pay for one if
my parents told me they were going to
disneyland by themselves i would say
who's after you
what did you do they usually bring like
kids or whatever but um yeah my they go
they they'll go by themselves what do
they get the kids
like
kids for the weekend the thing is my mom
loves it and my dad loves my mom you
know
you're really playing the heartstrings i
mean he well he they've nev he's never
been with anyone else
really he got with sex when he
yeah he tells you that yeah he told me
that
we talk we talk
gary huh we gotta play the field a
little bit pal oh yeah you're a young
man get out there
catch like you
no interest um all right we only i mean
we gotta wrap it up here but i mean
the whole lot of you is trash everybody
you've ever came in contact with it
sounds like any surprise parties
surprise parties yeah you guys do
surprise parties my mom hates surprises
okay how about trick birthday candles
the ones that keep relighting yeah i
think i've seen those at a family party
growing up we i had 13 cousins and so we
would all go to each other's family our
birthday parties and uh i'm sure those
have been around yeah i think peter had
a few shout out to pete shout out to
sweet pete playing the instruments as a
kid piano
but i was like
classically yeah i was really very bad
though so i read music i yeah yeah but i
in um
i think you're classy
but i was like a senior in high school
still doing it and the people in my were
like in sixth grade yeah because i never
got better yeah kramer in his karate
class yeah pretty much what the [ __ ]
yeah
janet haddocks a nice piano teacher just
never let me she was like we'll do this
one again
next up is mrs caitlyn
you're driving
i mean buddy
dead the rights trash all the way
through the dog
park farm you guys got a great you got a
great family your dad sounds awesome
you're close to your family that's
amazing you know we love you you're a
great kid
but my god
yeah no i knew coming on to this i was
like oh this is trash i am trash gnome
people is crazy but for the record gary
is all classy
gary can't be touched
ladies and gentlemen caitlyn paluffo
one of my favorites
one of the best well you're one of the
best what do you got cooking up what do
you got
uh is this coming out what's happening
uh next week next week i've got a real
business real quick what the [ __ ] gary i
was like i'll get it out today let me
ask you this hold on real quick okay did
you have braces as a kid yes because not
just how creepy you got good teeth thank
you i had braces i had headgear the
whole thing headgear yeah i knew it oh
yeah
my little sister they had to break her
jaw
[Laughter]
kid four sets of teeth like a goddamn
tiger shark
yikes we didn't even get into jessica
now
right beautiful way
i love her very much oh she works
she's killing it
anyway
so if you're in the if you're if you're
in the ba area check out jessica at the
trader joe's well honestly the date that
i was going to say is i'm doing alameda
comedy club in california and my entire
family will be there yeah yo gary
listeners go out i need eyes on gary
please yes you're at california go see
caitlyn she's amazing yeah yeah it's the
last weekend in april april 29th and
30th awesome it'll be out before then
yeah yeah oh great yeah come to that one
let's sell it out get mama a bonus yeah
honestly caitlyn is one of the funniest
comedians out there everybody loves her
she's amazing high energy you [ __ ]
kill it you're a worker
i don't know what else to say well thank
you oh my god yeah if they're saying
everything possible i don't know what
else it's just like oh my god
she's got good teeth i do i got good
teeth and i will masturbate to that
later thank you so much for saying that
is that too much is that it's not that
kind of podcast yeah it's not about
disney
we're not on a cruise
[Laughter]
to canada
strange
do you think alaska is in canada it's
near canada all right
it's to the left of canada yeah just
kidding canada banging left
bangalowi
start talking weird make a left
gang thanks for tuning in make sure you
rate review subscribe patreon come see
us we're on the road we're all over the
[ __ ] place yeah chicago we added a
late show that's how you [ __ ] sell
out um
everywhere phoenix arizona salt lake
city denver
uh
come see us let's [ __ ] party gang we
love you and we'll see you next week
peace
peace gary